you know australia needs what some kind
of like organized exorcism of activists
who oppose the the like overt
fascistic tendencies maybe like a group
that opposes fascism like an
anti-fascist group like we'll call it
antifa
yeah does australia have any kind of
like antifa that could oppose the
authoritarian lockdowns i'm just i'm
thinking that maybe if they got together
and congregated maybe we need a donald
trump in australia to like kick that off
you know
just just to trigger something yeah you
need to trigger some people in black
outfits running around smashing they
haven't say that they have antifa for
sure in australia i've seen it did you
see the uh the anti-focus oh there's
antifa there i know they've come they've
come to events of mine and like
extinction
have you guys seen the video of the
antifa people attacking the group that
opposed uh state mandates mass mandates
yes antifa shows up
and they start
they're anti-fascist but they're
pro-state they're statists and that's
why i keep telling people like do not
call antifa anarchists they are not
anarchists
absolutely they're communists they're
authoritarians and they're actual
fascists some of them yeah david graber
the late david graber said that there's
an element of the left that has adopted
the fascistic ethos of uh
well the fascistic tendencies not that
to say that they are fascists in the
academic sense or they are nazis but
they certainly believe a lot of the
exact same things around uh and that was
the extent of a twitter thread but they
do believe these things to the extent of
identitarianism government power and
control to the point where they'll be
like we oppose fascism and we'll beat
back regular americans who are upset
with government and corporate power like
in dc when a bunch of conservatives got
together and said we oppose corporate
power and centralization so
anti-shut-ups aren't beating people it's
like dude if you're if you're beating
people in defense of corporations and
the state you're a fascist yeah but hey
you're also probably ugly a physiography
check have you seen a lot of them
they're deformed looking and it's so sad
because
it really is true the rest is who the
joker targets haven't you ever seen the
dark knight yeah that he they go this
ideology targets people who are
desperate and unwell and so yes yes
you look at a lot of these anti-not
every single one of them but a lot of
them and they're they're dejected
anti-social and and unwell in a lot of
ways and so they're attracted to a
violent dogmatic mob they're not
fighting for anything other than they
feel pain and they want to cause pain
they look sick you know jason charter is
jason charter's the the antifa organizer
in dc that did he get arrested yeah he
was getting charged for for two a
decade's worth of of uh
of jail time simply because he tried to
pull down the andrew jackson jackson
statue and organize the siege on the
white house but that's what they're
alleging the insurrection yeah well
exactly that forced the president into
the bunker yeah the insurrection on the
actual white house um i i've spoken to
him i've had him on my show before too
and it's interesting because
when you speak to him you know he's
disabled he i'm not being rude he's just
got a gaunt looking he people thought
think he looks a little bit like maybe
he's on chemo or something like that
he's pansexual he said this on my show
and it's really i kind of actually felt
bad for a second because what i realized
is that
at a certain era or time in a different
world this guy probably could have just
been like this guy that would have been
rejected from society but now someone
gave him the chance to fight back and
tear down the regime to tear down the
statue to be known for something and he
fell into this trap i believe he fell
into this trap i don't believe he's
strong-willed or strong-minded he fell
into this trap and now he believes he's
like a martyr when really he's just like
a terrorist and that's that's kind of
the funny thing he's actually just
terrorists in the past something that
would have helped him what's what i'm
saying
but i'm saying like they could like help
them with some programs and get and get
find meaning in life and some counseling
and get his brain on intact but there's
this instead of helping the weak like
you're saying it's a society that preys
on the weak and what used to either help
or destroy is now about taking advantage
of weak people to carry out their deeds
yeah and that's what we're seeing now
too even with the coveted stuff is it's
all about praying on the minds of the
week and i want to say this is so
important but kez brought this about
australia because of of the rhetoric
coming out of dan andrews and and of uh
brazilian i don't know i thought you
said there clearly
the premiere of new south wales glasses
we see this here on a lesser extent but
what the the premiers are saying is
they they make you be obedient and then
they change the goal posts and reimpose
the restrictions and then tell you you
have to do a little bit more obedience
to get the restrictions removed and then
they remove the restrictions and then
they add them again and then at a
certain point they started saying
this is how the rhetoric went
the you who are obedient this sounds
like a regime you who are obedient the
reason why you
are unable to finally break out of this
constant cycle of lockdown and
totalitarianism is because the
unvaccinated the disobedient
are keeping you locked down
and you capitulated you gave it many of
you compromised you got the vaccine when
you didn't want to get it you you put on
a mask and you didn't want to put it on
you agreed with lockdowns when you
didn't think they were right you held
your kids from school and you know what
you know what's happening because of
this small group of people who are still
resistant you have to be punished again
and their resistance isn't just
affecting them it's affecting you and
it's splitting the population against
the subservient and those who are
independent and they're creating this
weak group of people who are more and
more capitulating and more and more are
giving in to hate the people thinking
that it's the unvaccinated that are
causing the problems but it's the
government who are causing them so it's
getting that it's deflecting off the
government it's like no the government
is causing the issues they're the ones
locking you down they're the ones
ruining your life they're the ones in
stating the the restrictions it's not
the unvaccinated people that are ruining
your life it's kind of weird because
like i agree with you to an extent but
just looking at the things that again i
have like all my friends and family
a ton of them are in australia and the
things that they say is stuff like it's
not that hard to wear a mess just wear a
mask and it's like
these are people who are conservative or
at least like who you know lean to the
right or who you know are libertarians
somewhere on the right wing somewhere
and these are people who are like well
just wear the mask like it's not it's
not that big of a deal because i think
the problem is that
and again i don't want to i don't want
to say mean things about aussies but i
think that to some extent people have a
hard time connecting the dots between
government overreach and how that could
inevitably lead to very very unpleasant
things further down the line which is
concentration camps precisely
i mean i know it's it's it's like it's
this it's it's not even an ironic thing
anymore it's it's like the worst thing
in the world that they're building these
quarantine facilities that people
somehow think are normal and again
they're they're literally building one
of them up the road or very very close
to where my family lives in victoria and
it's disturbing in a lot of ways to
think about again how and i was trying
to find the street for lydia just in
case she wanted to you know pop it up on
screen or something where someone had
basically taken these photos of one of
these quarantine facilities and said
well look how nice it is look there's a
pool and there are the people drinking
the coffee and oh this person's sitting
on a deck oh that's freaking great you
can't leave though
that's oh it's a nice bloody cage i'll
give you that but it's still a cage and
you're not there because you want to be
you're not there because you own free
will you're not there because this of
your own volition you're there because
the government put you there and you're
defending this and this is the problem
with australians again aussies are great
people nicest people wonderful people
kind people but they are butt heads
sometimes when it comes to this stuff
and this is why i wanted to get out of
the country where's where's antifa
they're i don't know sitting in their
home in their you know home screen has
there has there been a prominent antifa
presence in australia before not really
they tried but again aussies are very
politically ambivalent so to actually
get a group of people together who are
willing to go and smash things up is
actually quite where's where's where's
new york city antifa
i we could fly them over maybe maybe
they could um no i mean like in new york
where they've basically said all
disabled people ineligible for the
vaccine will be terminated from their
jobs on the 13th of september
i i don't know why you're asking me ask
elijah's right
or the antifa unfortunately they're the
ones thinking that and siding with the
state they're basically some of the most
easily manipulated piece of
crap people that uh unfortunately
i want to get this yes unfortunately for
us what they are doing is they are
pushing the authoritarian mandates they
are an extension of far left political
ideology and whatever the far left is
pushing this country they just side with
they don't have any original thought
they are well organized but as of right
now they are being used to bully people
and especially
what they are most being known for right
now especially is attacking
anti-lockdown protests even church
groups i'm sure you guys covered that in
portland they're attacking prayer
meetings break uh they destroyed an
entire ministry's office they're
attacking christians now because
christians are being seen as some of the
few purveyors who are against this
tyranny who would it be said that people
who believe in individual liberty and
liberty to christ would not want the
government you know coming down on you
the same government that also like
burned and hung a lot of them upside
down and you know also like kill jesus
but anyway
we
we actually need right now based on
based on what we're seeing in new york
we need actual people who oppose fascism
to stand up reject this to protest and
say no but nyt i'm i'm looking at uh nyc
antifun they just they don't care at all
they're cheering for the government on
january 6th saw that they love all this
sort of stuff they're like get them boys
something because they're not they're
not anti-fascists they just use that as
a way to recruit stupid college students
who don't know about her well angry
people too something that i wanted to
say actually at the beginning of this
show um and we sort of got very off
topic talking about cows and things was
it when you were talking about this this
legislation where you know the
government comes in and could put things
on your phone and all that i think
people need to realize that in australia
especially and i know this is the same
thing here in the united states and i
dare say in most western countries
around the world but australia has some
of the most psychotic legislation
pertaining to what the government can do
to you obviously um but especially
towards like terrorism legislation so
when they pass these extreme things
these extreme measures that are you know
in response to a terror attack or you
know covet or whatever the case is
obviously we all know that they never
appeal them but i think people need to
look into some some of the terrorist
legislation that exists in australia the
anti-terror legislation where like for
example when i was doing my master
degree
i did this ethics course and basically
we had to learn because it was my
masters in journalism we had to learn
about like ethics and you know where the
social contract all this fun stuff
and they were talking to us about how if
you accidentally stumble upon
information
relating to some of this anti-terrorism
legislation where you start covering a
story
that that relates to somebody who's been
detained under this specific legislation
you yourself can basically be arrested
for uncovering it and speaking about it
so there's all this psycho-legislation
in australia that's actually a lot worse
than what you're even talking about and
it set the precedent for worse and worse
and worse legislation that continues to
infringe the rights of aussies and
aussies don't know and don't care
because they're politically ambivalent
so once again we roll back around to the
fact that am i surprised that
australians are sitting in their homes
and have been sitting in their homes for
200 days plus no i'm not because this is
this is what you get with an ambivalent
population yes they want it they get
what they want i guess you know we get
we pay for it no refunds thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time